it's not about me joanna dong has a
question
she says my question to carl fristen how
do you explain the meaning of life using
the free energy principle that's the
easy question you can answer that in
like 10 seconds
um no i've never been asked that before
the meaning of life
uh so no i just got to use my favorite
words uh tautology and deflation
um you know the meaning is in the
existence
um the shape of that existence defines
the goals for the
existential imperatives to keep yourself
in the in those existential domains so
it's just
in the existence it's just the shape of
things that exist
that define their own meaning uh and you
know in a sense
um you could look at self-evidencing as
finding meaning
uh for your life or your
fine finding um or understanding
the um
the model for which you're trying
to accrue evidence
and what that basically means is if
you're reading that
as a um as a psychiatrist or a
philosopher
you're basically trying to understand
yourself and your own
genitive models so if you understand
your own purpose
or your purpose is just to aspire to
this these attracting
sets um that define you as the kind of
thing you are
and then the meaning would i think rest
upon this
some kind of self model where now you
recognize
you're this kind of person so you you
can spin it off at a number of different
levels
so it wasn't a very i'll think of a more
succinct accessory
psychologically and attracting set would
be what mathematically that's fine but
for someone who is just interested in
how one lives their life
is this just a recapitulation of know
thyself
yeah so the thing the things that the
the things that um
you are attracted to literally um the
things that you see yourself being
attracted to the things that you see
yourself aspiring and working towards
um um so what do you find interesting
and admirable
is that what you mean yeah yeah that was
that at a very high level
but remember you know this operates at
all scales
of of a deep charity model where
remember the the the core
is dealing with with sort of more
abstract things such as
you know being likable being loved being
rich
but at the periphery you know there are
still um
there's a model of basically body
temperature body pose
um not being in pain so
these are also things that make me happy
in a sense you know
these are the these are attracting
states it's attractive to be at a
particular temperature
attractive not to sense pain it's
attractive
um you know to be hydrated to a
particular extent
uh at some level it is also attractive
you know if you have very deep genitive
models
um that have this counter factual depth
then there are certain
counter factual outcomes that you would
find very surprising will be
unattractive
and there'll be other outcomes which you
would have learned
this is the kind of outcome that i
aspire to this is the kind of gender
model i
am you know at that point that i think
it would be
quite fair um to start thinking about
this in terms of you know
i'm going to develop this reputation you
know if i if i
say this or if i donate this or
i'm going to um i'm going to be this
kind of
person uh if i take these actions so
there are certainly entailed in the
prior
beliefs that constitute the genetic
model ways of behaving ways of being
outcomes that you a priori expect to
happen
and generally these are going to be
things that are consistent with your
self-image with the with with your
self model and interestingly also
require
um an optimism bias a sort of you know
because of this self-fulfilling prophecy
of all our actions and decisions and
choices and behavior
if they're all in the service of
realizing our
fantasy about the kind of thing that we
are
then we are always behaving and
selecting those information and
ignoring other kinds of information um
in order to find evidence that indeed
this is the kind of thing i am so i'm
going to ignore any evidence
that run runs counter to my self-image
you know that i'm not liked or not
believed or that i'm very poor or very
hungry
um unless i can do something about it um
so
um so you know so that's a real i think
it's a really interesting question
because
it it speaks to the um
both the self-fulfilling prophecy
and this sort of optimism optimistic
aspect of active inference which is not
a fallacy
it is it is absolutely essential in
keeping us on track
and keeping it as within these attracted
attracting
or attractive states so if you're doing
if you're a behavioral psychologist this
would just be
um some kind of reward if you're
a control engineer it would be some kind
of negative loss function
so you just score being in a given state
in terms of the probability that you
would find me in that state
and if it is unattractive and the kind
of thing i would avoid
that simply is a statement that has a
very low probability
that means that the negative logarithm
is very very high it just means it's
surprising
so it's just another way of saying that
the attracting
set of states or the attractive states
are those that i am not surprised
to be in that they are comfortable
they're familiar
given i am who i am this is exactly the
kind of state that i think
i should i should plausibly occupy